[Music]
united states supreme court in a 9
to 0 ruling stood up
for religious freedom and in just a few
months
this new united states supreme court
will take up maybe the most significant
pro-life case
since roe versus wade if you want to
hold on
to your faith if you want to hold on to
your freedom then you have to rise
and answer the call to defend america is
there a place
for religious people anymore
at the highest level of government
the answer after amy comey barrett is
yes so the supreme court this week
rules nine to zero in a big case
for religious freedom nine to zero
so what does that mean in the big
picture about the politics
of the religious right what does it mean
about
religion overall let's bring in our
panel
ben dominic publisher of the federalist
charles lane opinion writer for the
washington post and bill mcgearn
columnist for the wall street journal
bill does this change
the political calculation or is it about
the same
as far as republicans democrats looking
at this issue
i think it's about the same look nine to
zero
is a big victory uh for the catholic
social services on that you know you
don't sneeze on that
but it's also an indication of how
narrow this ruling is
that the uh the liberals on the court
didn't think they were sacrificing too
much
to go to it the more interesting opinion
in this case
was a concurrence that i would call
withering
by justice alito he agreed with the
outcome but he really attacked the logic
for not going further because basically
the court said
the in philadelphia the the
regulation on on this allowed for
exemptions and so as long as they allow
for exemptions
the court said you can't deny a
religious exemption so
as justice alito pointed out all they
have to do
if they want to have the opinion go the
other way is just get rid of all the
exemptions i don't think they granted
any other exemptions
and we're right back where we started
from right
aside from the specifics of the of the
case and
and the ruling been the politics of this
moment
do republicans see opportunity in this
moment
absolutely they do brett and one of the
big reasons for that
is what we saw happen in the last cycle
in 2020 you saw an enormous
degradation a significant degradation of
the support that democrats get from
non-college voters
and while the focus has mostly been on
white non-college voters over the last
several cycles they had a real hit when
it came to non-white
non-college voters people who tend to
value religion
more in their lives and are really in
terms of the cultural
cultural conflicts that we see happen
across this country
far more aligned with conservative
voters than they are
with the dynamics of the left in
bringing in all of these
former republicans these liberal
suburbanite voters
that democrats have won over the past
couple of years
they've also been pushing away people
who reject
that kind of secular agenda and i think
that that creates a huge opportunity
particularly among hispanic voters
for republicans to really make their
case that they will be on their side
when it comes to these culture war
battles
and that they cannot trust the left's
elites
you know you look at charles at the
fundraising the national republican
congressional committee
versus the democratic congressional
committee
uh may fundraising numbers republicans
14 million
42.1 million on hand uh democrats 10
million
largest off year may in in the democrats
history in that
fundraising effort but 36 million on
hand
it often comes down to money
yes and i think those large numbers
although you have to factor in the fact
that the rnc
itself gave a big chunk of that
that's represented the republican side
shows that
both sides are gearing up you know hell
for leather
on this 2022 midterm because they can
see
how narrow the existing majority is
republicans feel that with redistricting
and everything else they've already
practically got
victory in hand and don't want to blow
it for lack of funds
having said that i think we all can
point to evidence from the last election
cycle
that huge expenditures particularly a
lot of senate races on the democratic
side
didn't pan out candidates who were
outspent
in maine south carolina elsewhere still
held on to their
seats so message i've always felt is
much more decisive than money
once you get past a certain threshold of
cash that enables you to compete
bill where do you see the structure of
2022 i mean we're a long way away
but i mean you have big issues like the
border for republicans
like spending
foreign policy may factor in but where
do you see the structure
well i think i think it's changing very
quickly you know look at the last
last year's election the republicans
surprised everyone
by taking a lot more seats than anyone
thought they would
so it looked like a lot of voters were
saying i'm not with donald trump
but i sort of agree with the republican
principles i think the situation has
improved for them
because the greatest unifier for
republicans is joe biden
and he's gone down this progressive path
with this huge spending and taxing and i
think that's going to be an issue you
know a lot of democrats
complained about the defund the police
movement you know how that hurt them in
their races you know when you combine
this
with the traditional losses that the
party that has the white house suffers
in the midterms
that's a real challenge for them this
year and again i if the republicans win
no one will predict it because
republican gains are never predicted
and we're a long way away from 2022
and november